is it true
i am a big fan of fantastic four you've
heard the rumors
that you and john what do you mean don't
make a face
that you and john are going to be reed
richards
and his wife sue in the fantastic four
movie which i think would be a great
idea
no that is fan casting that and no one
has received a phone call that is all
um that's just people saying wouldn't
that be great and
and uh that's it no one has in a way are
you
too good of an actress to really
participate
are you too good of an actress to really
take that role
seriously in other words maybe that's
why you don't even react to this black
widow thing that you could have been the
black widow and iron man and that could
have been your franchise and blah blah
blah blah blah
because in a way maybe the whole genre
of superhero movies is beneath you it's
not that it's beneath me
it's not it's not that because i love
iron man
i wanted to work with robert downey jr
would have been amazing but i
don't know if superheroes are for me
they're not um
they're not up my alley i don't like the
superheroes or is it that a lot of women
i speak to
it's been exhausted i think it's just
that we are inundated it's not only
all the movies it's the endless tv shows
as well
and it's not to say that i would never
want to play one
it would just have to be something so
cool and like a really cool character
and then
in general i don't race to see superhero
movies and maybe because i feel
they leave me feeling a bit cold i can't
explain it i'm not
i can't get in there
what's up everybody it's warren and um
i'm not sure i really buy this i think
we've moved past the point of
kind of accepting when actors and
actresses
say they're not playing roles we believe
them i don't think that happens anymore
i think we really have to wait until
actual castings are announced and
besides i'm pretty sure that emily blunt
has spoken
with marvel and john krasinski her
husband as well
at least that's what's been reported and
that's what we're going to break down
because there's some things here that
i'm not really buying and plus i know
everybody is really excited at the
possibility of
emily blunt and her husband john
krasinski playing sue storm aka the
invisible woman
and reed richards aka mr fantastic
because i love both emily blunt and john
krasinski but if i had to choose one i
would actually
really really really prefer john
krasinski to play mr fantastic i think
that's a pretty perfect casting i think
it would be great to see emily as the
invisible woman
but if i had to choose one i would
choose john before we dive into it quick
reminder we're still giving away
stormbreaker at the end of this month
all you have to do is subscribe to my
channel subscribe to cosmic
culture and the details are in the
description down below so this kind of
seems to have people in a panic
people are stating now okay well emily
blunt and john krasinski
aren't going to be mr fantastic and the
invisible woman
but let me remind you of this and
command to ant-man
was oh that's all rumor man all right
nothing i know all right from her
emmy-winning role on orphan black
so marvel seemed like a perfect fit for
her
yeah well tatiana now says not so fast
in an interview with the sudbury star
yesterday
what's up sudbury tatiana said that
actually
isn't a real thing and it's like a press
release that's gotten out of hand it's
totally not
i've been connected to these things in
the past and press has gotten on to it
but it's
not actually a thing unfortunately now
obviously paul rudd is ant-man and
during disney's investor day they
announced that tatyana minslany
is jennifer walters aka she-hulk
so we don't need to start panicking yet
they cannot say
yes i'm going to be in the fantastic
four yes i'm going to be
the invisible woman my husband john
krasinski is going to be mr fantastic
there's just no scenario where they can
say that at least
not until it's announced by marvel
studios now it doesn't mean that they
are in fact
going to be playing sue storm and reed
richards but it seems like there is a
little bit of evidence that leads us to
believe that they are at least being
considered
by disney and marvel for those roles so
first of all let's start with emily
blunt
not too long ago when she was filming
jungle cruise with the rock which is a
disney film
there were reports coming out that she
met with marvel
and kevin feige the president of marvel
studios now again this
is during jungle cruise so it was filmed
at a disney studio
disney owns marvel they use the same
studios it really wouldn't be hard for
emily blunt to meet with
kevin feige in fact it would be very
very easy kevin feige could simply just
walk on the set they could have had a
meeting in her trailer they could have
had a meeting at any of the executive
suites in the studios
kevin feige's office isn't far from the
studios they could have easily done that
as well
so i'm not sure if i'm buying the fact
that she stated that she hasn't really
met with anybody at marvel yet and she
says no one has received a phone call
but she very well
could have just simply met with kevin
feige ran into him on the set at some
point in time but i mean obviously she's
going to just deny things she can't
announce
if she's sue storm she just can't now at
the same time
when john krasinski started his youtube
channel during the pandemic before he
sold it
he was getting a lot of attention not
that he doesn't normally but he was
getting a lot more he was doing a pretty
cool thing with his youtube channel
sgn some good news and at this time
where everything was taking place via
zoom it was reported that he actually
had
a zoom conference call with marvel now
there were a few reports that stated
that it could be about
directing john krasinski likes to direct
films now he's done a really great job
at some films
so that is a possibility but if they
contacted both him
and his wife emily blunt it seems like
mr fantastic
and the invisible woman would be a
perfect conversation to have since
they're married
and the two characters are married it
would be a great dynamic to see on
screen
now at the close of this video emily
blunt did say
that she wouldn't be against playing it
she said that it would have to be
something so cool
and just a really cool character for her
to get excited about it
well mr fantastic and sue storm the
invisible woman are two of the most
interesting characters in the marvel
universe reed richards is counted as the
most
intelligent man in the marvel universe
smarter than tony stark
bruce banner shuri he's the top dog and
sue storm is incredibly powerful and not
to mention their son
franklin richards goes on to become one
of the most powerful characters
maybe the most powerful character in
marvel history he literally uses
galactus
as a puppet to do his own work an
insanely strong character and if they
incorporate
him their son into that story in the
fantastic four
maybe it could be interesting enough for
her and her husband to get on board and
you also have to keep in mind that
kevin feige has already stated that he
meets with a bunch of different
actors and actresses about multiple
movies some of you may have heard me say
this before but kevin feige met with
jake gyllenhaal
about 10 times to talk about 10
different movies before they landed on
the role of mysterio for him
the same is with keanu reeves kevin
feige has admitted that he has talked to
keanu reeves about marvel characters
they just have not found
that perfect role for him this is what
kevin feige does he talks to a lot of
different actors about
a lot of different roles to find the
perfect people for the perfect parts
and marvel is kind of moving on now to
use a lot of mainstream actors
just look at the eternals cast angelina
jolie salma hayek camille nanjiani
kit harrington richard madden really the
whole cast is just stacked and if you're
going to bring in
two of the biggest names in the marvel
universe mr fantastic and the invisible
woman you're probably going to want some
pretty big actors to play the roles
but then again maybe she is telling the
truth they do have two kids and she has
stated before that it would be really
hard to commit to something for a very
long time
because of her kids and she did state in
another interview that it would be
pretty hard to go
and shoot a film because of her kids
however if emily doesn't want to play
the role of sue storm the invisible
woman we shouldn't rule out john
krasinski to play mr fantastic he may
want to play that role really badly
and like i said it's been reported that
he's met with marvel studios so
you never know now the fantastic four
cast has probably already been chosen
in marvel's recent teaser of all of the
films that they have coming up when they
announced the release dates and titles
for some
the fantastic four was the last project
mentioned with no release date but it
was mentioned nonetheless
kevin feige also announced the fantastic
four at disney's investor day
and he confirmed that they were working
on it already so
the cast has probably already been
chosen and if they haven't they
definitely have a pretty good idea of
who they want to play the roles
and i'm betting even if it doesn't
happen i'm betting john krasinski and
emily blunt are probably number one
if not top three for choices of who to
play mr fantastic and the invisible
woman
but let me know what you think what do
you think about emily blunt's interview
with howard stern do you think this is a
classic
paul rudd denying jeremy renner denying
tatiana and celani denying one of those
cases or do you think she's being
genuine
and if it's not john krasinski and emily
blunt playing mr fantastic and the
invisible woman who would you rather
have play them let me know your thoughts
down below in the comments don't forget
to subscribe to stay up to date on all
of the latest mcu news don't forget to
like this video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof